hello everyone welcome back to the good
stuff we are continuing the Morphy saga
with another game between patrols Morphy
and Samuel Standish Boden from 1858
London before you know our stunts and
gets ready for his match with morphine
supposedly and I still haven't decided
how many games I'm gonna show between
morphine and Boden but as long as I find
them interesting I'm definitely gonna
show as many as possible so I end two
very small announcements I am starting
the Ivan Madar Friday tournaments on
leeches so tomorrow will be the first
tournament and if you are interested in
joining I will put a link to it in the
description below so it's gonna be at 7
p.m. Central European Time it's gonna
last for two hours a three plus oh and
also I'm creating another tournament
which will be one hour prior to that one
which will be for sub a 1700 player so
if you are already lower than 1700 to
Dani
that's the tournament for you as you
guys requested you you want a one such
tournament so we're gonna do both of
them first the sub 1701 then the normal
one and then well I'm just gonna be
streaming both of them tomorrow and
we're gonna be showcasing your games so
should be a lot of fun and also I would
like to mention that I have well I
acquired the first guest for my podcast
I will not yet mentioned who it is but
you are you were more than welcome to
try and guess in the comments section
it's someone from the chess world so
that being said let's check out the game
morphe again opens with E 4 we have E 5
and again more filled with white pieces
goes for the King's gambit so f4 we have
Bishop to c5 declining it as Bouldin
already did in the game we've shown
Knight f3 we have these 6 and c3 now
more features preparing the bust open a
with d4 we have the shop the g4 painting
more fees night and now Bishop the c4
are nicely developing we have Queen to
e7 and now d4 and interestingly already
as a move 6
this position was never repeated again
so boarding characters that we have pawn
captures and Morphy often did this
you wanna as castling was not allowed
because of the Bishop on c5 so here
morphe gives up some material to be able
to castle the safety so we have e
capture sandy for morphe now just
castles and now Knight to c6 by border
not being greedy and going for captures
with check king each one and then
characters here which would fully
develop more fees bishops and with the
black king being still in the center of
the board would be very hard to play a
modern player would definitely accept
such challenge but they're bored and not
interested so tonight's the c6 now
boardin continues development and now be
four more feet now continuous expansion
on the Queen side we have Bishop to b6
and now a for preparing a5 to trap the
the Bishop here so the captors on c3 and
now freeing up the d4 square and now
comes and this also comes with check of
course so King to h1 and now here comes
c2 by Boleyn forcing Queen captures and
c2 so Morphy that's it of course and now
Bishop captures on f3 the idea is that
if now morphe captures with the rook the
knight before just for to the Queen and
the rook and Bowden wins a lot of
material here so instead morphic played
G captures on f3 and now Knight captures
on before attacking the Queen Queen to
b3 and a5 defending the knight so here
more if we really give up a lot of
material as you can see it's a 7 points
the morph is 5 and well it's just all
everything's all over the place that the
king is on h1 the Kings the King side
completely shattered but for the moment
there is no actual good way for black to
attack the King side however this is
Bishop slicing all the way here to g1 if
you know some pieces find their way near
more amorphous King could get very ugly
but morphe normally just continuous
development Knight to c3
we have Knight to f6 and now II five
keeping the black King in the center of
the board for as long as possible
d captures a wave F
Capra's on e5 in now of course not
capturing with the Queen you have to
keep the defending the f7 pawn so
tonight's the h5 and now comes Knight to
e4 again more features starts bringing
pieces in front of the black King and
Bowden here decided to Castle kingside
which is a bit odd as the King does
appear to be much safer on the Queen
side and also you want to attack more
face King on the Kings side so I I guess
Boylan thought that his King would be
safer on the Kings side for some reason
but Murphy just continues development
developing Bishop to b2 now both of the
bishops are slicing over to the Kings
side and now Knight to f4 by ball and uh
taking up a lot of squares in front of
Murphy's King
now if Queen to h4 then already even the
Queen joins the attack maybe the root
can also join the game and could be it
could be very very interesting but
Morphy here now shows him what it means
to play again against Murphy here Murphy
goes rook to g1 he offers the rook and
now probably you should capture it but
if Bishop captures then you recapture so
you still have a look on the G file and
the it's still hard hard to defend for
example if King h8 you get e 6 opening
up the dark square bishop and now you
have to play a move like f6 to block
both of the bishops and it's a really
tricky position but okay our board and
for the moment decided not to capture
the rook he went to rook a to b8 but now
more he finds it at the very exciting
east 6 now opening up the dark square
Bishop and now the problem is you can't
go into the the line that we've already
shown the problem is if you go captures
now rook captures and f6 now it doesn't
work f6 is bad here but even pause the
video and try to figure out why f6
doesn't work here and it worked a moment
before while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations unsporting
that at some point when this pawn is
pushed with check you will be attacking
the rook here which was previously here
so by playing rook a to d8 Boland
is no longer able to go for this defense
because now Knight captures on f6 with
check you're gonna play rook captures
Bishop captures and the Queen captures
now pretty much only move and now e 7
check will win you the rook on the 8th
after the king moves king here you're
gonna bring the Queen into the game
Queen captures and you get the same game
where more fee would be up up the
exchange so that's why this rook 888
prevents such a defense but Bowden
played it here so he can play Bishop to
b4 to block more fees dark square bishop
and now more fee goes for he captures an
f7 with check we have king to h8 and now
rook to g4 getting the rook Adam out of
harm's way and also perhaps it will be
possible to double rooks later on on the
G file so Bishop captures and be doomed
this was Boden's plan Queen captures
threatening checkmate and now there's no
good way to defend checkmate other than
to go rook captures on f7 and try and
give back some material also Knight to
g6 is a possibility but then you get to
rotate the g1 slowly white will start
pushing and that Knight will not stay
there for very long so rook captures an
f7 the engine very much agrees with
Boden
it is the best move Bishop captures on
f7 we have Queen captures and now Knight
to g5 with an attack on the Queen we
have Queen to d5 Queen to f5 is a little
bit better here but but okay
Queen to b5 now with the rook queen
battery along the D file but now comes
Luke captures on f4 bone and said it's
no need it's not needed to defend the
Knights and some I can always character
on g5 but that's exactly what more if he
goes for rook captures on f4 okay queen
cat person g5 and now rook the g1
offering the rook here for a nice
checkmate on g7 so what do you do here
Quinta h6 was played Queen to e7 was a
little bit better but well you know you
can't you can't have everything and
always play the correct move here both
and defended with Queen to h6 but now
the problem is that morphe is able to
add even more attackers rook to f7 was
played by morphine now with a triple
attack on the G
and pawn here as you can see Boren
definitely would work the g8 but now
rook captures on c7 and now there's not
much black and do your queen and rook
are stuck here guarding the g7 pawn so
go and play Knight to b3 but now more if
you just played Queen to b4 and it was
in this position on move 30 that Samuel
Standish Bowden resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
you could your knight is under attack
you have to bring it back but now I
pretty much anything wins for white you
could just grab a pawn here but even the
straightforward route captures and g7
just wins on the spot because if you
capture with the rook rook the C it is
made since the rook is now pinned and if
you capture with the Queen then of
course morph it would happen we win the
Queen and then let's say check look
blocks and then you pick up the a five
point and black will not have much to go
on it will be a very quick win for white
so after Queen D forboden resigned and
yet another victory for Paul Morphy in
their in their match like I said I'm
gonna I'm still gonna decide where to
show more games between the two of them
as if I if I decide more of them are
interesting I'm definitely gonna show
them before we go to mountains next
minion of course mr. Barnes the
legendary mr. Barnes but we'll see how
it goes so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it do check out the links in the
description below join the tournament
tomorrow it's gonna be it's gonna be
great
so I will see you there I would like to
thank Robert Vasquez
Christopher Drake Peter morganson
Sebastian Berg and Thomas Jonah Cody
most for contributing to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Morphy
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day